نزحنا من الشجاعيه طبعا من غزه على الشفاء
قبل الشفاء اول شي على الشفاء بعد الشفا
واحنا واحنا جايين على على
الوسطى ضربوا صاروخ
الكويتي الله
نجانا الله نجانا يعني شفنا هالاشياء
وشفنا يعني متنا الف موته لما شفنا
هالمناظر اجينا على الصارت على مدارس
لصارت قعدنا في النصرات الدبابه صارت ترشق
يعني مراه حامل انقطع راسها واحنا بنطلع
فيها مراه حامل على شهرها يعني ربنا نجلها
الطفل كمان وهي راحت وبنت عمها صاوبت
وامبارح اودي واقفين على الشباك الصف
القناصه في قلب الشباك طلعنا نصوت ونزح زي
ما انتم شايفين ويعني اقول لك معيشه غير غ
صعبه للغايه وهذا احنا في السقعه نمنا هان
الفرشات ثلج ثلج احنا نمنا علىل الليله
اكثر من هيك معيشه لقينا الناس لقينا
الناس قاعده ه اجينا زينا زي ه الناس زينا
زي هالناس اللي بصير عليهم بصير
علينا حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل والله العظيم
يعني والله العظيم ميه مالحه انا انا انا
يا انا مرفت ادبر ميه له الصغار اشربهم
انا ع تنفار واخوي ع تنفار واخو الثاني 10
تنفار وجوز اختي بيجي سب ثمان تنفار والله
العظيم امبارح ولادي ما داقوا اللقمه ولا
اولاد
اخويا يعني ايش قعدوا
يصيحوا ايش هذا يعني اطفال اطفال زي هذا
يقعد يقوللي بدي خبزه في
الليل ايش يعني حمامات لا ميه ايش اعمل
والله نمنا على الارض على الرمل هان زي ما
انتم
شايفين
ن